SNL lets Nikki take a swing while Trump
says he looks like the king today's
video of the day comes to us from Nikki
Haley who popped up on Saturday Night
Live and she fit right in by not being
funny she played the role of a concerned
South Carolina voter in the opening skit
questioning a fake Donald Trump in a
town hall and she showed all the
Charisma of a 5B bag of allpurpose
flour roll it
Fran my question is why won't you debate
Nikki Haley oh my God God it's her the
woman who was in charge of security on
January 6th it's Nancy bosi are you
doing okay Donald you might need a
mental competency test you know what I
did I took the test and I aced it okay
perfect score they said I'm 100% mental
you've spent 50 million dollar in your
own legal fees do you need to borrow
some money oh Nikki don't do this Nikki
Nikki Al Joel Osment we call her 6 cents
remember that one I see dead
people yeah that's what voters will say
if they see you and Joe on the ballot I
don't know the only dead people we see
are the writers for this show not to be
overshadowed Trump went on Instagram to
point how similar he looks to the king
of rock and roll take a look there you
go
see it's
uncanny so maybe Elvis didn't die he
just dyed himself orange and went into
real estate meanwhile Joe says he's not
going to participate in the traditional
Super Bowl Halftime interview Dre it's
the first time the NFL said a president
had too much head
trauma what does Joe think if that's
indeed possible no no no no look look I
I want to do it I I didn't want to do
fox last year I'll do CBS those guys are
softies Scott P nor O'Donnell I I'll do
both of them I'll scratch pelle's back
while I'm smelling O'Donnell's hair they
like when I
do but it's my staff they don't want me
doing it they think I'm going to say say
the wrong thing I'm good I I got a plan
if I lose my train of thought I just
whisper works like a j if that fails I
just tell one of my famous stories yeah
like the time I was working in all black
Polish restaurant in the Puerto Rican
section of Korea Town and I took out K
pop with a
[Applause]
perogi Marly the fact that he's not
doing the Super Bowl interview says a
lot it's like a three-minute interview I
mean I think most of the questions are
like who are you rooting for what are
you eating it's a three minute interview
with one of the largest audiences in the
world like it is such a gift to a
politician to be able to do that and
yeah the questions are in no way going
to be difficult and I think the team the
Biden team knows that he is so unpopular
that just seeing him actually bothers
people there was the poll that came out
this weekend showing that he's just
getting smoked in every demographic car
uh category versus Trump yeah it's funny
it's like I think they really worry Rob
that if he could just say one thing and
it's
over you know yeah this is a Highwire
act for an election sure sitting for
three minutes no one is sleeping
probably in either camp but definitely
his no one's sleeping well but can we
just take a moment we have him here yeah
to like
appreciate what Tom's the work that
Tom's doing being uh President Biden
you know know what is okay what is I
mean I have to say honestly never been
much of a fan but this is good this is
good stuff no you know it's what what is
weird about the the Tom's impression and
I was going to get to that but now we've
jumped over there Rob I guess we should
call it the Rob long show anyway uh hobo
tonight nobody expected you to say
anything nice so I had to jump in no but
you know what it is is like that uh Tom
like estimated how Joe would be oh and
he started like degrading Tom started
degrading himself and then like Joe
started catching up and the degradation
it was weird it was all of a sudden
there were times when I was watching Joe
Biden like on Twitter or something and I
go what that's Tom yeah I thought it was
Tom or you think oh Tom that's a little
that's a little too on the nose that's a
little too much dementia oh damn that's
actually Joe Biden yes exactly I knew it
I'm Joe stradamus yeah
oh terrible joke Tom do you uh what did
you do you think Nikki uh should have
done SNL I think no politician should do
uh any comedy show ever they're never
funny M uh they always look weird yeah
and they always look like that great um
Steve Bashi thing hello fellow kids you
know they always look like uh Bob Hope
and a hippie wig it never works yeah
exactly try to be cool cat um Trump and
Elvis that was a stroke of Genius
isn't that you know what I love about
that well you know what I love about
that is that Trump is could be
incredibly silly at any moment and just
like take the piss out of everything and
then it's just like that's Uncle Trump
well I've seen it be reported on a lot
like in the true sense of reported on
like Trump trump thinks he's Al and I'm
like G Jee no um but going back to the
SNL thing quickly this proves that like
every body knows she's not going to win
because they wouldn't have her on there
and be nice to her like that if they
thought that she had any chance of being
the nomination or getting the nomination
because if she does then they're going
to have to apologize for like
normalizing Nikki Haley or whatever
because they you know remember when what
people were thinking maybe Ronda santis
was going to be the nominee I mean years
ago and I never did by the way so um
people were like oh is he maybe worse
than Trump so the fact that they're
treating her so nicely means that they
don't see her as anything threat to him
I think it also shows that they that
Nikki Haley's only job here is like to
tear down Trump and SNL also wants to
tear down Trump so the problem is she's
pretending to run for the Republican
nomination and that's not going to get
her far no it's not you know Tom I just
came up with a great idea you should do
at in the halftime of the Super Bowl do
live on X a three minute
interview I might have to do it I have
to do
it if we can get Tyler F together to do
Trump and you guys could do it together
but that's a lot of work and I'm
lazy Sunday I don't well we'll see what
we can do Greg yes yes yes car to
comment on a Nikki Haley B Donald Trump
C there was something else in there uh
yeah okay Nicki Haley not funny not not
a surprise um yeah the the brilliant
thing about Trump with this meme is I
don't even think he looks like Elvis he
just wants people talking and that side
by side it's like does he look like
Elvis or is that half Elvis half Trump
you know what is it but then Biden
weighed in on it this is what's so funny
he weighed in on what is Trump's
strength which is this kind of weird
Meme and it makes you think because then
everyone's talking who does Trump look
like Elvis whatever and then the next
thing you think of is well wait a minute
what does Biden look like and I'm
thinking like if anything it's that uh
you know the the skull with hair on it
in the Iron Maiden
logo like I couldn't think of anything
else that resembled that's so true you
know that has a name the Iron Maiden uh
he's on every cover he's got a name and
I I I hate that I can't remember it Jeff
Joey Joey it's Joey I take my audience's
word on that all right we gotta move on
people are just calling out
names Eddie it's Eddie oh they act like
they know now oh it's
Eddie there you go all right up next
Does Elon have the tools to save our
schools
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else